and you said you'd want to invest your
own money in this that's what you said
here
yeah i i would love if anyone wants to
do this i will 100
invest so please email me um but this is
one of those things where like
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right everyone we have a special
episode with andrew wilkinson andrew
wilkinson
started this company called meta lab
which grew to make tens of millions
of dollars and using the profits from
his agency uh meta lab he eventually
bought
dozens of more companies so he's
collectively his companies do hundreds
of millions of dollars a year in sales
and have created over a billion dollars
worth of value so he's uh
seen a lot of interesting stuff and in
today's episode we talk about
an incredibly success successful
business person that he looks up to it's
our segment called billy of the week
and then we talk about some of the ideas
that uh he has for starting growing
companies
he currently launched a local news
business so it's kind of like my company
the hustle but for different cities
it's very fascinating i've i'm asking
him if i can join as an advisor
and he started a few more things and or
wants to start more stuff and he's even
said that if you are starting some of
these companies to holler at him because
he wants to invest
so give it a listen and by the way if
you're in miami shawn and i
on june 4th are going to be in miami
we're doing austin on june 3rd but
that's already sold out but
june 4th we have room for up to 400
people i think already 200 people have
rsvp'd it's free
um go to uh my twitter handle the sampar
and scroll down you'll see the event
eventbrite link it's totally free june
4th it's friday
uh come and uh by the way we've been
working our ass off
to make content for you just for you
can you do me a favor and click
subscribe in itunes
and click follow on spotify when you do
that we go
higher up in the charts which means more
people can see us which means we get
more views and if we get more views we
can keep doing this more and more and
more because we're
making some more money from it and we're
able to dedicate more time to this so
please
i work my butt off for you just click
subscribe and click
follow on spotify and subscribe in
itunes i appreciate it
hope you enjoy the episode andrew what's
going on dude hey man how you doing
i got a really bad really bad cold i
spent all day yesterday with kleenex up
my nose so uh
if my voice sounds a little froggy
that's why it only sounds froggy because
you said it sounded froggy i think
you're okay
so andrew wilkinson good friend of mine
good friends of the pod
is this description that i used three or
four weeks ago the same description is
that is that the same thing
are you wearing that same personality is
that the same life or have you done
something new and amazing because you're
always pulling something out of your
sleeve
uh yeah i've got i think since then i've
launched a couple businesses actually
but no the description's still accurate
um and so we're going to talk about a
couple things the first thing we're
going to talk about
is well you got a bunch of ideas here
i'm excited for the ideas but i want to
talk about
billy of the week because we talked
about two people
last time you were here and that was uh
it's right next to
the biology episode as the most listened
episode ever
really no way which episode was that the
bill the one where we did the two
billies
yeah something like i think almost 50
000 people listen to it which is
like it's an hour-long thing it's a lot
of time crazy
um and then the third most listened
thing was the one we did after that
so you know it could just be it okay
yeah
it's the other side uh move aside sean
yeah so
it's like biology is like uh whatever it
is you're like
within hundreds or like a thousand of it
and then you're the next two
and so that's why i figure we'll start
off with that one but you sent me i
yesterday i asked you
to tell me an interesting person and i'm
gonna go do a ton of research on them
and i did
and i have a feeling you already know a
lot about this person but what's this
what's this person's name
so his name is uh i don't know how to
say it i think it's
george apollo it's a brazilian named
oh there you go okay can you say his
name please and every time we need to
say his name we'll just
say brayu i'll say his first name his
last name is german so i don't know if
there's a right way of saying it but his
first name is joshua
is his considers his first name as well
because in a lot of the articles i read
about him they call them majarje
sorry george apollo it might be his
middle paulo might be his middle name or
it might be like a double first name i'm
not sure but josh
this guy's totally mysterious he doesn't
like to talk about what he does
uh there's only a few interviews with
him online um
but he basically i mean if you think
about the businesses that he owns
you would know them so burger king uh
budweiser tim hortons
craft foods popeyes heinz ketchup right
so he basically goes out
he finds these amazing you know
multi-generational businesses that have
been around for 50 plus years
that do something very very simple
that's just gonna grow over time
he goes out he usually raises a ton of
debt
and then he goes and buys them and takes
them over and he's been doing this
for i don't know 40 years or something
like that starting in brazil
let's give a little bit of background of
him um so halsey he's about 75 years old
right um and he's based out of brazil
he's a brazilian guy and when he started
at the time i don't think that there
were these like brazilian tycoons you
know every article that i read about
they said that he was one of the first
folks in in brazil to become
one of these uh private equity or warren
buffett like people
out of brazil and like you said very
little is known about him and he doesn't
give interviews and in a lot of the
interviews that i read about him they
said we
actually tried to talk to a bunch of his
friends and nearly all of his friends
said
you know thank you for reaching out but
he's politely asked us not to
speak about him in interviews so he
prefers to stay behind the scenes and
the way that his career started and is
uh in 1931 at the age of 32
he had some jobs beforehand where he was
a banker but he started this one bank
uh abreu you want to help me out here
here's what it's pronounced here's how
you pronounce it you see that right
there it's called
garantia i don't see it
did you put it in the chat it's
highlighted it's highlighted in the dark
i think it's garantea or something like
that
okay and it was described as like the
goldman of brazil
um i don't know if it was described at
the time like that but
he was 32 when he launched it it was
and what made it kind of famous was he
had a very uh i wouldn't call a
laid-back culture but he didn't look at
resumes but instead he looked for
uh what he described as psd which was
poor
or let me see what does psd stand for
poor smart and deep desire to get rich
yeah poor smart and deep desire to get
rich that's what he looked for was
people who had psd
and he would hire these folks and
in previously at different companies you
would automatically get a bonus if you
were one of the partner but they created
some type of system that was
uh they tried to make it as based off of
merits as much as possible so
a lot of different people could get
bonuses and also the bonuses you could
choose do you want more stock or do you
want more
cash and it was a great way to
incentivize people and it kind of
created this
iconic culture that that seems what
they're they're famous for
and it grew to be quite huge it was
something like a billion dollars in
profit at one year
but he said that they got cocky and they
screwed up they
they overbought some stuff and it
eventually went south and it sold for
650 million dollars which is a
still a ton of money but i think it was
minuscule compared to how big it got
so i have a question for you andrew and
then we're going to get into this 3g
thing so then after he sold it for 650
he started buying gillette stock
and with his other older
founders at the old company he started
3g which was a play on their name and
there was three partners
and they ended up buying uh burger king
um
tim hortons all the companies that you
said and at this point he's worth
something like 25 billion dollars and
one of the one of the richest people in
the world
um but i had a ton of questions uh that
about this guy
that i think that you might know or at
least you have a better input than i do
the first is how on earth like when
people say they're starting a bank like
he did
what's that process like that sounds so
ambiguous and so hard to understand
well i think like people hear bank and
they think like oh a big pile of money
like wells fargo or something
but bank the term banker means so many
different things it could be somebody
who works at a bank and lends out money
or whatever
but a banker is really like a real
estate agent for businesses
right or for bonds or equities or
whatever it is so
it's like a person you go to or a group
of people you go to
who will figure out problems for you and
facilitate transactions
so let's say you sam go i need to raise
100 million dollars of debt for the
hustle because i need to expand
a banker will go out and they will go to
all the wealthy people they know and all
the different you know corporations and
say
hey here's this great guy you should
lend money and then they take a fee in
between and so
in a lot of ways is the world's best
business you're a middleman on these
huge
transactions multi-billion dollar
transactions and you're taking a two and
a half to five percent fee on everything
you do
so with like 50 to 100 people you can do
crazy amounts of money
what skill set so when this guy started
at 31
uh 32 what skill set would he have
needed in order to make this happen
well it's really heavy on two things one
it's like sales and stuff and then the
other is kind of financial acumen and
modeling and all that
so you'd probably get a bunch of people
in the office who are like super
hardcore spreadsheet junkie excel types
who can like
figure out you know how to structure a
deal and then you'd also have people who
can do the very high level sales right
so they're basically smooth talking and
calling and selling and positioning
everything
to facilitate all the deals do you
consider yourself a banker
no i actually generally really hate
dealing with bankers
um and i i think it's kind of like real
estate agents right like i'm very
skeptical of real estate agents
i think in the next 50 years they
probably won't exist
a lot of the time a real estate agent is
just a person who puts up a listing
online for you
opens the door for a few people and then
takes a huge fee
which seems a crazy and out of line
right and and now there's great real
estate agents let's say you have a weird
property that might not sell
they know how to spruce up there's one
there's one in a hundred that's amazing
and will sell your
property for more but a lot of the time
they're useless and the same thing is
kind of true with bankers i think if
you've got a great business and you want
to raise money
you should just go and call a bunch of
wealthy people and try and raise the
money yourself
because at the end of the day a lot of
the time what bankers do is
build some decks and then breathe on the
phone while you talk to other people and
then take a huge fee
how much money have you raised uh we've
raised
maybe uh well it depends it depends on
how you think about it so
um i would say in the neighborhood of
about two
200 250 million or something like that
if you include our ipo
or our reverse takeover we just did not
including that what's a 100
200 maybe oh so the the stack that you
did
wasn't a six including it was 60 million
that was that was how much we raised
when we took that business public
wow so then your funds have well over a
hundred yeah
and you didn't use a banker for any of
that no we just called people we knew i
mean we had we bumbled into this world
like i had no idea
five years ago six years ago even i
didn't know what the difference between
a banker and a bank teller was
i had no idea and because of that we
just kind of kept meeting
interesting business people and as you
met interesting business people they
keep saying hey
are you guys raising money because i'd
love to invest with you and so
eventually when we had big enough deals
that were interesting and we wanted
partners
i just called those people and we did it
ourselves so back to this guy
he uh like when you're starting
something like this and this is i
you like this guy because i imagine like
you
you you kind of want to you want to
steal some of his life right i mean you
want to you want you
you you want to emulate some parts that
he's done yeah
well i think like we're probably similar
in that like we're both attracted to
these
really simple businesses like selling
beer or
razors like there's both of us come from
like this weird tech world where we do
this like
knowledge work you you write an email
newsletter i do a design
and then two years later it doesn't
exist right i like the longevity and
the kind of simplicity of more
traditional businesses so i love that
and i think the idea of just buying
these super
safe boring steady eddy businesses that
do something simple in the world
and just making them better actually
sounds like a lot of fun
and i wrote a note below but the key
thing
about that what he does is um
generally they have one key insight
right so it'll be something as simple as
when they bought budweiser
it was on the third generation they'd
gotten super rich right so it was like
the first generation built it
the second generation like were amazing
they went to harvard they grew it
the third generation took over they got
sloppy
didn't really care about growth they had
fancy offices and private jets and stuff
and so when they bought it they just
look at it and go oh it's been run in a
kind of a sloppy way and they've lost
their discipline
we can buy it with a lot of debt and
then we can just make it way better
pay off our debt and then we own
budweiser and so it's this crazy coup
for these guys from brazil
who you know they came from basically uh
you know started at zero
although i think they were you know
upper middle class in brazil
but starting there to owning budweiser
is crazy and i want to ask you about how
to get into those deals and when i read
about him it sounded like he
was the young guy of a three-person
partnership um
which definitely i think he's actually
the old guy so there's the two younger
guys
the younger guys actually go and they
run the businesses so like one of the
partners
i believe went in and runs um
runs uh what is it called qsr which is
like owns tim hortons and all that stuff
sorry i meant from his first thing so
his first thing got him his big nut
his first thing made him like 650 or
they sold for 650
and from what it sounded like it was
like a a little bit of an older guy who
had a little bit been there done that
kind of brought him along and he was the
young guy of that partnership
totally yeah and then he did the same
thing and now he has younger partners
right and um and so i have i had a few
questions about this but
i wanted to so let's just talk about
this guy's strategy at 3g in
his whole life it seems he's done the
same thing which is he's
a cheapskate he's frugal he's incredibly
frugal um
so he's done a couple things like he has
a few like phrases that they would say
which is like
he's like costs are like fingernails you
have to cut them constantly
and he would do famous things like when
they bought burger king they banned
color copies meaning when you're using
the photo copy machine
uh he was like just black and white only
um
you also what was this thing you said
about private jets they
also force people to print on both sides
they'd say you not only can you not
print color but you have to print
double-sided
um so the first thing they would always
do whenever they buy a business is they
sell all the private jets
immediately right and let's be real most
fortune 500 companies have like
between 1 and 10 private jets and they
just say f
that we don't need those they sell them
and it's kind of a statement
and then from that point on the new ceo
and all the executives they have to fly
economy
and they have to stay in motels and they
all
they it's i love that right i think it
just sets the tone from the top
in a really interesting way and these
are people i mean the ceo of abe
imbev he's probably worth like hundreds
of millions of dollars and he's staying
at like a quality inn
but i think there's something to
demonstrating that at the top if you
want your lower
lower level employees to care too i
actually think that that's a stupid
thing so i get
staying at cheap hotels because changing
it staying at like a marriott courtyard
which is like a 89
a thing i'm on board with that it's
probably even cheaper it's 50 bucks
i'm cool with that it's just you can
have a fine clean comfortable place
although i do like having room service
because if you get into a place late you
want that
but whenever these people say they fly
economy i'm like that's kind of stupid
if i'm flying overnight
i need a comfortable i need to be
comfortable so i could like be
ready to roll you know you're like you
don't want your athlete to like work off
the two hours sleep
um do you actually believe that people
do that i think they do i mean
maybe it's just lore uh maybe these guys
are super rich and they pay for it
personally or something like that
but um i i don't know i mean i think if
you're i know like walmart has a big
corporate jet
um fleet and they actually have a really
good argument for it which is
they're constantly visiting stores and
that's their way of kind of like
whipping
all the store managers and making sure
they do a good job and so
they have all these tiny little jets
that fly between
small towns and if they were to fly
commercial it would take
10 days to do two days of work so i
think there's a good argument for it
there
but i can't imagine the ceo of abe imbev
needs to be flying all over the world
constantly if he's flying once or twice
a month
it's not a big deal to be on a
commercial plane or whatever i just
think it's kind of a
i think it's a neat thing to do i
personally like
you know i i wouldn't i would feel bad
like i would be worried that i'm gonna
get the
worst ceo because they want like their
perks or whatever
but the kind of people these guys hire
like these guys when they took over
burger king they hired a 35 year old as
a cfo
right or maybe even a 30 year old and
the owner is the ceo
yeah yeah i i wrote about it they hired
a 32 year old who
was part of their management company and
he took it over
and he kicked ass a few things that he
did was
at the time burger king was was trying
to advertise predominantly towards young
men and he goes no
we're going to be for everyone so we're
going to advertise for everyone um
another thing that he did was remember
the king burger king like the king yeah
he was like that's kind of creepy get
rid of that
um and then the uh the third thing that
he did was at the time burger king
employed something like 28 000 people so
they owned most of their restaurants and
they would hire the people
he goes now we're going to switch to a
franchise and we're going to help all
these franchise owners line up alone so
you guys can make your own places really
nice and we're going to help you make it
nice and that was the big switch that he
did now burger king i believe crushes it
and this is we've seen this in our own
investing like often having one
thesis right so the thesis could be hey
margins are really shitty
you know they're they're five percent
they should be 15
and we can do that via via very simple
improvements
or something simple like this burger
king deal where
they went into big debt and they
actually paid up a really high price to
do it
but the insight they had was well as
soon as we take over we're just going to
spin out all of our corporately owned
locations and franchise them
and by doing that we're going to raise
all the money to pay off our debt
right and so they did that and then they
ended up taking it public with ackman
actually
um and did insanely well in it oh that's
interesting
and when they did it
there was a funny story about the guy um
who we're talking about uh i'm gonna try
and
say his name one more time uh what is it
i wanna when i see it i wanna say jorge
um but anyway
he um so there's a funny story about him
that
he had never had burger king until
they bought the company and it was like
a multi-billion dollar deal he didn't
eat it
until they bought the company and when
he ate it he was like ah this is too big
and he's known for like really only
drinking water and eating really healthy
but he owns
you know non-healthy stuff what's your
take on that do you think that
does that rub you the wrong way are you
like oh no i think i think it rubs me in
the wrong way i think
he sounds like he's really good at kind
of being secretive and pr that's exactly
the sort of thing i wouldn't want to
give out i wouldn't want it out in
public or whatever i think it sounds
kind of
lame so this type of business um that
you like
and i i enjoy it too but um would
when i was reading all about him would
you say this boy to me it boils down to
you have to be good at fundraising money
so you have to be good at getting
convincing
some type of rich institution or rich
people to give you money
the second thing you have to get good at
is you have to recruit really really
talented people typically people that
are
highly recruited at other places
typically people who can start their own
thing typically people who are probably
already wealthy you have to hire them
and then third and probably most
important you have to be really good at
inspiring and leading them so you have
to be a leader of leaders
is that like the three three pillars to
this am i missing
exactly you nailed it it's really and
it's really really hard the hardest part
is recruiting the
the amazing people like our biggest
challenge isn't doing deals it's
like we could do a deal every month it's
how can we find enough amazing people to
run all these businesses
and then how can we validate that
they're going to be able to do what we
need from them and you know you think
about like
that 32 year old he was probably working
in head office for 10 years and they saw
all this stuff but it's a huge
chance to hand that to him and that
could have gone really really poorly
um but i i think that's exactly that's
the warren buffett playbook right it's
like how do you
be a leader of leaders how do you give
them positive coaching without
like getting too involved in the
day-to-day and
the fundraising part actually seems like
the easiest the fundraising honestly
like
it was so when we did we have a we have
a fund and uh which we raised during
covet just because we thought we were
gonna get mobbed
and it was really weird we actually was
like like we thought we were gonna have
this
no no we thought we were gonna have like
overwhelming amounts of deals to do
and we thought it would be a great time
to have excess capital
and uh that didn't happen right everyone
was actually
weirdly optimistic and the government
wrote the check and all that stuff
but um but doing doing the money raising
wasn't actually that hard like
running an agency for or owning an
agency for 15 years and doing sales for
a long time like
that's easy you just have a fun
conversation with someone you walk them
through a deck you point to your track
record
that that was totally fine the hard part
is really the execution of the actual
deals and hiring the right people and i
would argue
i mean i don't know really what i'm
talking about entirely
strictly from reading it seems like
executing the deals
is hard but it's not that hard
the hard part is really the people part
is that
we i we've done deals we just did our
biggest deal ever
um and it was over 100 million dollars
and it was no more work or complexity
than doing a one million dollar deal and
in fact it was simpler than a one
million dollar deal because it's just a
better business
with a better team in place and more
momentum
has always complicated people uh well in
our in our public company we bought a
company called stamp which is one of the
top ratings and reviews apps on shopify
um there's a
110 i believe total uh it gets paid out
it's a structure you'd have to look at
the press release for the exact
structure but wow that's in around there
and
when i was reading this i'm in the
middle of reading um human nature by
robert greene
and the reason have you heard of that
it's an amazing book i've been reading
that too
have you really wow it's amazing isn't
it crazy it's so good
it's so everything he does is great and
the laws the laws of human nature isn't
it called right yeah the laws of human
nature
and i already read it and now i'm
rereading it again but i'm studying it
like i was
like i'm taking a semester of robert
greene and the reason why
i am reading it is because i thought
that when i was getting into business
all that would matter is like business
and you're like well what's business
it's like i don't know
um uh like i guess selling stuff
making the product really good um in my
business it was like i'm just gonna
write words that people like
like it's really simple but what i've
learned is
it's far more important to understand
and motivate human beings and have
really
effective day-to-day interactions with
people
and in order to do that you have to have
a little bit of a
i'll call it like a machiavellian type
of thing to you where like people
love you yet they're a little bit
fearful of you
they kind of view you as like a little
bit of mysterious like you have to
attract these people and they have to
both
want to be around you yet think that
you're formidable and be a little bit
like nervous of like oh man if i don't
join this person
they're going to crush me and live up to
your expectations
what do you mean well like basically how
do you one of the things
like some of the some people i've worked
with have this thing where
you just want you always want to raise
the bar and you always want to live up
to their expectations so they say
this is the bar this is what i expect
from you but they do it in a very
flattering way like you're really smart
you work really hard i'm so impressed
with you
i know you can achieve this right and
then they set this crazy bar
and you just naturally want to live up
to the expectations and i've always
struggled with that
uh well just different different partner
business partners and stuff have dealt
with over the last couple years
um but but uh like with employees and
stuff i've always had this habit of
wanting to be liked
and i still want to be liked but i want
to be firm and i want to
have boundaries because in the past what
i've done is
in wanting to be liked i've excused like
somebody failing and said like it's okay
don't worry about it
it's fine and then i'd quietly just
dismiss them
and then not use them for tasks like
that whereas i think it's actually
really important to be like hey look
like
it's okay you effed up but like you let
me down and here's
why you let me down and here's how this
impacted everything or here's the bar
and here's how what i need from you and
whatever it is and i've always been
terrible at that
it's crazy i mean elon musk has it bill
ackman who you know has it this guy
who we're talking about he definitely
had it when i looked at him and i like
would see how he would dress and how he
held himself uh
you know travis kalanick kind of has it
where they're just like
you're just you're afraid of them in a
way of like they inspire me but like
um they they can crush it like
whatever they whatever they set their
mind to they're gonna get done and
that's regardless if you agree with
their ethics or not
but you definitely could agree that like
these guys are good they're going places
there's a great story about uh sheryl
sandberg at facebook i forget who
who told this story but she goes i was
in a meeting with cheryl
and i you know i gave this presentation
and then she walked to me outside and
she said
during your presentation it was great
but you kept saying like
only stupid people say like and you're
not stupid and then she walked away
right and you can look at that and go oh
my god i can't believe she did that
that's so mean
but the way she told it was like it was
a kind of a backhanded compliment
that told her something that was
embarrassing it's like saying like hey
you have like
you know you have lettuce in your teeth
or whatever you don't want to hear it
but like it's helpful
and i think i've been very bad at that
kind of stuff i think you need to give
more firm feedback
that's stories from um erratic uh
candid or whatever that would be a
radical candor it's a good one
but um as i was reading this guy i'm
like man in order to get into some of
these deals like heinz
um whatever in order to attract these i
mean
basically like um this guy and
the folks that we talk about and maybe i
think you as well andrew
that you're like uncommon amongst the
uncommon
and you have to lead the killers so like
you've got to be the killer amongst
killers
and that is kind of like a fascinating
thing to think about because
to bring it back to what i originally
said when i got into business i thought
it was all about coming up with creative
ideas
it's like no i just got to be a leader
of men and women and that's
really hard so i've been studying how to
do that and i've been studying
like war leaders been studying you know
who really is good at this like
celebrities like marilyn monroe it's
like it's basically kind of seduction a
little bit
um and how do you just like get people
under your spell
and hopefully your spell is not positive
but
i don't yeah i think like there's a i
think it sounds stressful though like
the idea of like i'm gonna be a killer
and i'm gonna you know do all this stuff
and be machiavellian like i really don't
i don't like that
feeling of like feeling like i'm
manipulating someone what i like to
think about more
and what's been more instructive for me
is just reading psychology like robert
cialdini and all that stuff
and figuring out incentives and one of
the things i've learned is that
if somebody is incentivized to not work
as hard as you or not care as much as
you they won't
right so people do whatever it's it's
shocking but they'll do whatever
whatever the financial or day-to-day
lifestyle incentive is
where they can take the path of least
resistance they will and then they'll
create their own narrative for why
they're doing it right they might say
i'm not working hard because you know i
don't like my work environment or
whatever or there's a problem with
management or whatever it is
but often it's actually them just going
why would i work harder i don't make
more money
right i don't get a bonus for working
harder i clock in my time or whatever
so i think a lot of the time this stuff
is just an incentives problem and that
that's pervasive through everything
going back to realtors they have an
incentive to just sell your house for
the lowest price
to get it done to get to lock in their
fee they have an incentive against you
i agree with you that that is part of
the that is that is
that is a portion of it i would say that
there if there's two portions those are
both them
but i think you're totally full of [__]
in that you don't care about this
because you do
your pers your your public image is
and i don't know if you mean to do this
or not but i'll tell you what your image
is it's like you're like a cool guy like
you dress
nice you've got slick back hair you're
good looking you have these cool glasses
you're a designer i mean brother look at
like
the website what's the url of tiny um
tiny capital tiny capital you use the
same wonderful imagery used like you
have a brand
and a brand is is exactly this
machiavellian thing that i'm describing
of how to manipulate the field i don't
know
emotion ugh i don't know i think you're
the word machiavellian but you are
manipulating people to feel a certain
way
oh absolutely no no absolutely but it's
like copy right like knowing how to
write good copy what you're really doing
is
you're taking people along for an
emotional journey by using various words
right
and there's two ways to look at it one
is oh it's who's super manipulative
or the other is no you're trying to
communicate and you're an effective
communicator
right and don't get me wrong we
definitely do like
yuck up the kind of the softness of what
we do
but it comes from like you know we dealt
with wall street bankers we dealt with
people trying to acquire companies
they were shitty so this is me going oh
well
i hated that how can i market to those
people who have the same hatred that i
did
or whatever but yes there's definitely a
lot of public
public image stuff that we think about
so we'll wrap up with this billy of the
week
uh segment but what's your main
takeaways from this guy
and um there's a book about him it's
called like greatness i think
i i couldn't find i only saw it in
portuguese i don't know if there's an
english version
yeah it's called uh oh what is it the
dream big
dream it's on amazon yeah it's quite
good i read it maybe four or five years
ago
what's your main takeaways from this guy
why the biggest
what can i learn from him and what
should i avoid i think it's like you
don't need to do something innovative
and crazy right you don't need to be the
next elon musk or start some crazy
technology you can just choose a
traditional
business that's very poorly run and run
it better
and i you know even better if it's a
business that's low risk
growing and kind of successful despite
bad management
or you know bloated cost structure or
something and you
wrote something in here that was
important
which is different than how i perceived
you as doing which was
um you need to be comfort comfortable
taking on outside capital and having
partners
well i think like for this exact
structure right so what they do
they raise a lot of debt and that allows
them to have
you know a lot of control because they
have debt but it's silent it's not
involved in the operations
and that gives them the ability to just
like overrule and take over
um and you got to raise a lot of money i
mean if you're going to go buy heinz
ketchup like
that's not the kind of deal you can get
like a crazy deal on
you're going to have to pay the highest
market price for in order to do that you
got to raise a lot of money
compared to what we do like we're not
buying the heinz ketchup
we're buying the like random local
ketchup brand
right that's like been successful in a
small niche those deals you can find
oh and i i want to ask one more question
before we wrap up actually so
i actually was thinking about this so
like you're further along
you're a few years older than me not
only a couple years older but in terms
of like career success
you're you're a fair bit ahead of me in
terms of like you know we're both going
down the same path
um and then one path in front
of that you're friends with guys like
bill ackman these folks that are worth
you know billions of dollars in that and
and yeah like they're just
doing [__] so like along this path let's
say of the spectrum of people doing
stuff
it starts with like a scrappy internet
nerd in their bedroom like you and i
were
and then it comes to like alright you
get a little bit of success like i have
and then it comes
like all right you're starting to like
move things a little bit but even you
said you're still a pipsqueak compared
to like
you know enactment or whatever what how
does this this transition from going
from like
someone who's kind of interesting to
like a mover and shaker
on at a global scale how do you
does that kind of seem like a crazy
transition to you because
it's kind of like you're not far from
that it seems
um but like these guys like bill ackman
when they say something they're
in the news when they say um when they
like make a trade every once in a while
it can like impact millions of people
yeah i mean i don't i look i just look
and look up and
see how far we have to go i still feel
really really small
and you start you know like you know
when you like you're running your
company and you're like
you tell people like oh we do a million
dollars a year in profit and to you
that's like a crazy amount of money
and then you realize oh my god there's
businesses out there that do 30 million
or 100 million or a billion dollars of
profit every year
and the numbers just keep getting bigger
i just find as we get bigger
i just start talking to people who have
businesses that are way bigger and you
know it's funny you mentioned ackman
i mean ackman i don't know what he's
worth probably like
four or five six billion dollars but
this george apollo guy he's worth 25
right and so everyone's looking up at
some some person that they want to be
and someone doing bigger stuff
i think um it's kind of like the analogy
i would use is if you're an athlete and
you start out as just some casual high
school athlete
and then you end up in the olympics and
you just keep rising up and doing more
and more stuff
and eventually you look around and go
like whoa holy crap i made it to the
olympics this is crazy
um but i don't necessarily think it buys
you any happiness or
a better life necessarily and i think
there's a really interesting decision of
well do you want to be a mover and
shaker is it worth
all the downsides i think there are
quite a few no [__]
i agree um all right let's talk about
some ideas
um what we're going to talk about is not
necessarily an idea but something that
you're working on right now i want to
talk about capital daily because i've
seen you
i've seen this from the beginning and
i'm getting updates this latest update
sounds pretty amazing
yeah so i mean the last two years oh
actually let me just zoom out and i'll
say talk about what happened so
basically
uh i read the newspaper every day uh i
would read the new york times and wall
street journal
and read all this incredible
investigative reporting and then i would
pick up my local paper which is called
the times colonist here in victoria
canada
and it was just there's nothing it was
like
they didn't have any journalists they'd
laid everyone off and it was all just
like ap
wire service so it's like international
news and i was like how the hell do i
figure out what's going on in my own
city
and i realized there was a few people
doing local reporting but there's this
gap there
and so i thought okay well if i want
this i'm sure other people do
and i looked at buying the local paper
actually but they wanted like a crazy
amount of money
they had like printing presses like you
know unionized employees it's like a
cruise ship not a speed boat it'd be a
pain in the ass to buy it
and so i went to a friend who is a um
a stay-at-home mom who had some
experience doing a bunch of writing
and i said hey why don't we just start a
mailchimp account and we'll come up with
a brand we called it capital daily
and we'll send out a daily newsletter
and we'll just summarize like hey here's
like three or four stories of things
that are happening in town
so we start doing this and i i have a
friend who runs a ppc agency and i get
him to just go buy ads and i realize
i can buy ads for like nothing no one's
advertising for local news
break that down uh so you're saying you
you had a friend that
would buy advertising to get new users
and
you said hey could you see if you could
run some ads to get
uh email subscribers to capital daily
yeah i was like how do i get this to
scale
as quickly as possible a i saw an
opportunity and b
i realized that in local news usually
there's one winner
right so historically there's usually
been one big newspaper and so i was like
how do i get this as big as possible
as fast as possible and i was also just
impatient i was like i have money
i can afford to do it i'm just going to
spend like 200 grand on ads
and so we spent i don't know 100 200
grand
and very quickly we got to like 25 000
subscribers
and i just started hiring journalists
and uh built out a team and
it was it was crazy like i would be in a
cafe and people would stop me and be
like hey
are you the capital daily guy like thank
you so much it's amazing like the first
thing i do when i wake up and drink my
coffee
is read your newsletter and that was an
amazing feeling like i've got all these
other businesses that are like big
and i've never ever ever felt that sense
of community and just like doing
something important and so
i was having a lot of fun with it uh we
started hiring a whole bunch of people
and uh we realized like hey this is hard
like
the advertisers don't understand it like
people who buy newspaper ads
they're just stuck in their ways they're
old they're like all boomers and stuff
and so we're having a really hard time
selling ads i also built this big news
team
and was like burning all this money and
i was kind of freaking out going like i
don't know if this is
have i got myself into some trouble here
but a little over
six months a year ago i partnered with
this guy farhan
and he had scaled the biggest local news
site in vancouver
and he took over as ceo and now he's
monetized it
and i think we're gonna break even very
soon on uh the local stuff in victoria
um we've started selling out ads and i
think like on a unit economic basis
where we look at victoria
it's now profitable uh and it can be
very profitable if our membership model
works
and we've started expanding so we've now
got uh six or seven different
newsletters in different areas mostly
here in canada
um and we're scaling i'm i'm super
excited about it
so is that over story media group yeah
so go ahead i it's funny we like
we chose then i like the name overstory
but we got
cute and we were like oh overstory media
group is omg
and that looks cool as a logo and so we
chose overstory media group but then now
everyone calls it that and i hate that
name but i really like overstory
okay overstory so overstory is the
parent company that owns capital daily
yeah dude it looks like you have like 50
people working there
yeah we've we've scaled a lot over the
last little bit
are these almost like a big bet yeah
these are all pretty much all full-time
people
how much did you invest to start this
business
uh i think at this point i've probably
spent
two just over 2 million bucks but you
have to remember
that probably the first 700k was just
me me not monetizing it soon enough and
just focusing on building the audience
first
so i think we probably spent 200 250k in
ads
and then we probably burned an
unnecessary 500k like hiring the wrong
people
and kind of like experimenting so really
like
at this point we have the biggest news
business
in my city for probably 750 to a million
um and i think that business can
probably at scale
probably do 500 to a million in profit
once we're actually like
going so i feel pretty good about it but
now we're taking this bigger bet that
you know we can basically roll out local
news across canada
and farhan is your coach he's like the
the co-founder yeah and so you attracted
him because
you go i'll put up the money if you run
it exactly
like i said look i've already kind of
got this thing i've proven the model out
and uh you know he was looking for his
next thing and it was one of those
things you know when you just meet
someone and you go
oh my god i want to do business with
this person and they just have the right
background like he'd done he'd spent
like five
ten years doing the exact thing that i
needed
um so it's a total no-brainer dude i
feel like this is a much bigger deal
than you're making it seem
yeah it's pretty crazy what it's become
and it's you know it goes back to
i have in total uh i spend a lot more
time on this business than the others
because it's like a passion project
and i'm a consumer of it right i read it
every morning and i give them feedback
uh and i think i annoy farhan with like
daily texts about it but
um i've only really spent a few probably
less than a week of time on this
and the key leverage point has just been
uh bringing farhan on board
because when farhan joined it was just a
single newsletter with like
three employees um so now i mean he's
gone out and basically said look like
axios down in the states is aggressively
expanding their local and i think that's
because it's gonna work and it can be
profitable
let's go do the exact same thing in
canada
and so you're gonna hope how's the story
gonna end do you think
i don't know i mean i think that if it's
true in victoria
it's probably true in a lot of other
places um
the interesting thing is trying to
figure out like
you know what topics people really want
to hear and are they really variable
city by city right so for example like
we expanded into
langford which is a suburb suburb here
and it's more working class
and so it's figuring out okay you know
what are those people want to hear
uh versus somebody who lives you know in
in victoria or in vancouver
do they want different topics like you
know just that kind of stuff i think is
going to be really interesting to figure
out
and what's your membership your
subscription going to be
uh we haven't announced it yet but we're
kind of thinking about like
somewhere between 100 and 200 a year uh
getting local discounts access to events
maybe like a member-only newsletter
uh and extra content and stuff one of
the things i really want to do is start
hosting events in person because like as
you know it's one thing to see a number
of like oh the hustle has a million uh
million subscribers but when you meet up
with people in person
it's crazy so i'm really excited to like
fill a room with all the subscribers and
just see what that
feels like yeah me and sean are going to
miami we just posted about it and we got
um
like 300 people signed up great uh um so
yeah
wow this is amazing i can't believe you
didn't ask me to be part of this dude
so frustrated maybe i maybe i will i i'm
i
have it's all just my own money at this
point so if i decide i gotta go big i'll
definitely hit you up
i'm very interested you gotta make me an
advisor i think this is gonna be sick um
all right you wanna talk about another
idea so you
we'll talk about the baker thing in a
second what's this um which one do you
wanna move to
let's do the pregnancy stuff okay i
think that's cool what do you want
yeah this is like a business in a box
this is one of those things that i would
do if i had time but i don't
i think it's a really good idea so um
people love to spend money on their kids
making their kids better smarter feeling
like good parents and stuff
there's all sorts of like you know baby
emotes are you know different
uh health things people do for their
kids but nobody really thinks about
health during pregnancy and i think this
is something that's really important
that's totally overlooked
my son was born early he was born like
three weeks early
and low birth weight and he's fine like
we haven't had any health issues or
anything but any parent who's gone
through that knows it's absolutely
terrifying
and i started researching it a ton and i
realized that there's all sorts of
things that you can proactively do
to ensure that you have a really healthy
uh
a really healthy pregnancy but then also
to um like basically optimize your kid
so if you think about it
your kid is growing a brain and a body
they get to do that
once right like this is the building
this is the foundation of your kid
and so i started researching all this
stuff i talked to a really smart friend
my friend dr ronda patrick
and basically i realized there's like
all these studies that show that
kids and mothers who have like fish
and dha supplements b vitamins make sure
they're not anemic and stuff
it minimizes any risk of pregnancy and
it also maximizes
iq and general flourishing adhd all this
other stuff so there's this huge
in marketing the most important thing is
to have a hook
and the hook can be fear right how do
you avoid this terrible outcome
and one of the problems with doctors is
when you talk to a doctor
they just don't want to scare your wife
during pregnancy
and so they just say take vitamin d or
do this thing they don't explain why
and so i think explaining to mothers
here's why you want to do this
here's all the potential bad things you
can avoid and hey you can make your kids
smarter and better in the process
there's a huge opportunity to basically
do like roman
or hymns but for maternal health so you
do blood work
supplements that get delivered on a
schedule and it's about building like a
super baby
and you said you'd want to invest your
own money in this that's what you said
here
yeah i i would love if anyone wants to
do this i will 100
invest so please email me um but this is
one of those things where like
every three months i'm like why the hell
hasn't anyone done this yet
well there is a but there's a reason why
you shouldn't invest in this
which you've written here yeah i think
it's a
this is a great business for someone
who's never done a business before
because it's a good like launch pad
business it's something that can make
like
you could be big but there's no
competitive barrier right so you're
gonna go out you're gonna do this then a
bunch of people are gonna copy you
and you can probably make a good living
on this i don't think it has like a moat
necessarily except for maybe like a
brand that mothers
share or something but i think there's
something here
have you heard of the there's this guy
named um
i forget his name uh joel maybe joel on
writing is his blog
and he says there's ben and jerry
businesses and then there's
um ben jerry's versus amazon
is what he says he goes but ben and
jerry it's like a unique interesting
brand
and a person can go to ice stream five
days a week
and try all types of different stuff and
everyone can survive
and the only thing that separates ben
and jerry is just that it's slightly
different
but there's enough for everyone to
succeed like you know there's a there's
enough space we can all win
and you can grow it pretty slowly for
100 years and it could probably last for
100 years and probably won't go away
very easily but then there's like an
amazon which is you can really only
you really are only going to subscribe
to one amazon prime
and once you give your credit card to
amazon save it you're probably just
going to continue to use that and so
with the ben and jerry business it's
okay to go slow it's no big deal you
don't have to raise a lot of money you
can grow slower so long as you're
willing to do it for 20 30 years it can
get big
you've got to get huge really fast um
because everyone can copy you it's kind
of like rome's and him there's a reason
why like there was like five right away
because someone saw it oh hurry up copy
it you could spit this [__] up in three
weeks
but him the only moat here is size it's
literally a form
if you think about what hymns is the
original website was a well-designed
site they put some like
they find some stock images that are hip
of like pill bottles they add their logo
onto it so it looks like it's a special
thing
and then they literally have like a form
you fill out and then a doctor just goes
yeah rubber stamp okay i'll do it i'll
send the prescription or whatever and
they've gotten way more sophisticated
but at the end of the day
there's no lock-in other than the fact
that i happen to subscribe with them
and so other people just go out and you
end up basically competing in to
whatever the cost of the ads is
if it costs two bucks to convert someone
then you can make five cents per
right and that's what happens with these
businesses but i think for a year or two
you could probably make a lot of money
we first started this i said we should
break this up into two i actually think
we should break it up and
we should keep it as one and because you
have to go with the
10 minutes past right yeah something
around about about
115. so you have this thing called what
is enough money i 100
want to talk about that so let's talk
about one more one more idea
um and then we can come back you andrew
has a huge list of ideas we'll
save these and and do it for the next
one but what um
which other idea do you want to go to
yeah this one's really
this is a really weird story but so my
whole life i could never burp
um so my brother would like burp in my
face and i'd be like what the hell how
do i do that i just couldn't it was
really really bizarre
and you know i'd drink like pop and i'd
feel bloated and crappy and i couldn't
burp but it wasn't a big deal i didn't
think much of it
and uh and then when i was about 23 or
24 i started getting this weird
acid reflux and i just get this shitty
feeling of pressure and then
acid reflux and it started happening day
after day after day
and it started driving me absolutely
crazy and so about seven or eight years
ago
i started researching it and i knew
nothing about health i knew nothing
about diet
and i just basically had to figure
everything out myself and i tried
everything i tried
drugs supplements i had like you know
stuff
you know surgeries where they stick
stuff down your throat and put cameras
down there i had a wire put down my
throat to check on my stomach acid
i did acupuncture like everything and
nothing worked
and finally after seven years of
researching this
i was on google and i i thought about
this burping thing and i was like i
wonder if it's that
and i found this reddit community called
no burp oh
there's this huge community of people
who also can't burp
and on that community there was somebody
and they said look there's this doctor
in chicago
and he injects botox into the
cricopharyngeal muscle in your throat
and it allows you to burp and so
basically the reason why people can't
burp is they have this weird muscle
that's too tight
so i flew down chicago about six months
ago and i got this injection and now i
can burp
and i don't get acid reflux anymore and
my life is literally like
25 better i'm happier like this was
actually driving me insane what was your
first burp like was it like have you
seen how the colorblind people put these
glasses on and they could see colors or
when basically
i actually put it on twitter i put it on
twitter i'll find it for you and we can
share it in the show notes
there's a video of me burping it sounded
it sounds insane too
right like i just like yeah it's like
one of those videos where the dog gets
home and hasn't seen the owner for four
years like i'm just like
i'm very emotional but uh it sounds
effed up now i can burp like a normal
person
do you have 35 years of gas built up
dude literally like
i didn't know i didn't know what it was
like to just feel like release
right i just always had pressure so so
anyway so
i would have spent a lot of money a lot
of money to figure this out and i tried
all sorts of stuff i looked at like can
i go to the mayo clinic
like whatever and the problem is that
the medical industry is just very
fractured
so everyone does one very specific thing
and there's no one that brings it all
together
and most gps you know they are
primary physicians they can help you but
they're not going to go deep on an issue
and really spend time on this and so i
think there's an interesting business
opportunity i don't know how big it is
but this idea of a medical advocate this
is basically a project manager for your
problem
so you'd say like i have diabetes or i
have a rare condition or i have this
symptom
and they're going to go to every
doctor's appointment they're going to
get you into the best specialist they're
going to push the doctors to do testing
they're going to look at all the
outcomes all the data read all the
papers
and i think this is the sort of thing
that wealthy people specifically would
pay a lot of money
and especially if you could make it
outcome based where you say
if i cure this for you what's it worth
to you i think this could be actually a
pretty big business
so two things the first have you heard
of a concierge doctor
yes so i have that uh basically i pay of
and and i have it because someone like
got it for me when i was like
really ill um this billionaire lady it
was a crazy story that i'll tell another
time
but basically i um have this doctor
named dr horowitz and i just text him i
go
hey dr horowitz um my achilles really
hurts me can you schedule an mri for me
or something like that
uh and he's like yeah i think an mri
would be good i'll hook it up so they
you know and i paid an annual fee for it
25 000
and um would that not be this
well it i think that's very i have that
as well but i think it's very driven by
whatever you want right so you text them
you say you want an mri
but if you say hey my back is hurting
the question is is he going to be able
to have time to spend four hours a day
researching your back specifically and
figure that out for you
is he going to have time to go to all
the doctors appointments and interact
with all the specialists
and negotiate with them and everything
that's what i'm looking for is like
someone to be in the room to solve
problems
because i think a lot of people have
like a a loved one gets cancer
and they're like well how do i navigate
this like what's the optimal treatment
what am i missing am i talking to the
wrong doctor like what advice is bad etc
kind of like um a health a health
manager
totally specifically around an
issue or like you could do it around
specific issues but i think
i think it's kind of like a a weird
niche i recently heard about a business
where
all they did was negotiate uh bills for
hospitals
and it was a like a a very small number
of people and this business made an
absolute killing
and that kind of turned me on to these
niche medical areas
did you um look into the there's this
thing called
a mayo clinic um executive
what's it called a mayo clinic executive
i forget exactly what it's called but
have you seen this where you pay uh
executive health program you pay ten
thousand dollars and you go to a mayo
clinic and they have like five of them
or six of them
and you basically spend two days i think
or three days and they
look at everything of your body and try
to diagnose anything i mean have you
seen this
yeah i looked at doing that and what did
you why didn't you
well i started looking into it and what
i realized is that they were just gonna
recommend the same
thing that i already looked at right
when i talked to i think i talked to a
doctor
and he said oh yeah you're probably
gonna have to have this special surgery
which is like they they do like a
surgery on your throat to close it off
from acid
and i'm like holy crap thank god i
didn't do that that has like a million
knock-on effects
and all sorts of issues why wouldn't
this work
well i think the hard part would be is
it insured
maybe not so you're paying out-of-pocket
how many people really want this is this
just something like some rich people
want or is this a real
opportunity and then also like just how
much can you charge for it
um i think it could be a great business
for one person it could be a great
business for 10 people
maybe it can scale i don't know i like
personally i like the pregnancy health
one more
but i think the other one is more just
something that's needed especially
around
if you specialized in like cancer or
something so it's like
when your dad gets diagnosed with cancer
there's like a clear person to talk to
who's like an advisor who's impartial
can we um i'm just going through this
i think it's interesting i think that
this is
it's i sometimes i'm partial to these
like rich people ideas aren't you
like i'm like i'm like it's cool but i
don't know if i want to do that
i think it's it's one of those things
that is probably
a business but it goes back to like we
have a warped view of it
it go and you know we'll talk about the
enough money stuff later but i think
the interesting thing that seems to
happen the theme i see with people who
make
good amounts of money and become
comfortable is they just make themselves
uncomfortable again
by obsessing over all the stuff that can
go wrong like getting you know health
issues car accidents you know
how can how can it all get taken away
exactly um
let's talk about that so you wrote
something here that immediately caught
my eye
and it's something that i've been
reading over and over again is called
what is enough money
and we you and i talked about this
recently basically i told you
the goal when i started the hustle was
by around 30.
i wanted to make enough money that right
up front
like my nut would very passively spit
off
fifty thousand dollars a month in
perpetuity so 50k
or the equivalent with uh including
inflation
every single month forever and to do
that
you need like you want like between two
to three percent of your portfolio to be
able to do that so
what's i don't know what whatever that
do that math that's that minimum but
that was my goal and
yeah i mean i i i did it um and
you started talking to me about what is
enough money so what were you gonna say
here
yeah i mean i i loved you came back to
me and you just said like
to me enough money is like 25 to 50k
a month in perpetuity with very little i
said 50.
and the reason i said 50 is i spend way
less than that but i wanted to be
incredibly conservative yeah so you'd go
on a vacation and be crazy and not worry
about it
yeah or i think that's the right that's
the right way to think about it i think
the problem is a lot of people go i want
to be a billionaire or whatever and it's
like
what do you really want it's like well i
really just want to be able to like do
whatever i want every month and let's be
honest
50k a month even 25k a month is enough
to do whatever you want
for the rest of your life and so people
often will ask me like
oh what do you know what do you aspire
to be or who do you admire most
and i think like money is like i i use
the
athle like the athlete thing the example
before of like
olympic athletes i think like
billionaires are like olympic athletes
but let's be real olympic athletes
many of them have no personal life
because all they do is train and they
destroy their bodies by the time they're
right and so the people i actually
really admire i admire those
sorry i admire i'm impressed by those
people i love their dedication i love
that they do that
but i don't know if i personally want to
work that hard
or become an olympian i think what i
aspire to be is to be the casual tennis
player who
is always challenging themselves loves
playing plays with friends all that kind
of stuff
and so if you think about it from that
perspective um the people i'm jealous of
are the people who have 10 to 25 million
dollars
in a conservative passive investment
they've paid off their house
and they're just set and they have a
great balanced lifestyle
um i i love that kind of stuff and i
don't know if i'm i think i'm too much
of a maniac i think like i'm too
anxious and i always want to do more and
more and more i have a lot of fun with
that
but so it's hard for me to stop but
those are the people that i'm jealous of
there's a lot to unpack there first of
all if you're jealous why don't you do
that that's a good question i just don't
think my personality is
is really suited for that right i i
always
i always want as soon as i have like
freedom
i fill myself up again right and i'm
trying to crack that right now of like
what's driving that is that fear
is it anxiety is it just that i love
doing this
i don't know i mean it's easy i got the
same thing it's insecurity
um like you want to it's all it's
rooted in a fear of am i good enough to
do like i want to com
and it's ego as well i think it's it's i
have to prove that i'm better than bill
ackman
or whoever it is like you're at this i
don't i don't have that no i don't i
don't feel that what i feel
is like it's more it's more
fun new things and what i've realized
about kovit is like
i hated working this year because all it
was was the work
what i actually love is just like
meeting new people
right it's like it's just an excuse to
like meet new people and solve fun
problems
i know that sounds very kumbaya but for
me it's very true
without i all this work and all this
more stuff is meaningless to me if i'm
not like hanging out with cool
interesting people and learning new
things and making new friends
that's all i care about and so like
starting the news business even like
that was an opportunity for me to be
like oh who are journalists
i get to you know get to know
journalists who live in this whole other
world
outside of business where they care
about totally different things and i can
like nerd out on this new topic
and make a whole group of new friends
what would happen if you just turned off
your phone or changed your phone number
and
not opened your computer ever again and
never read your email
or for like a year what do you think
would happen if you did that and you
came back to tiny
i think i'd be fine right we just did
this at tiny we changed we don't get
monthly reports anymore from the ceos
so like there's businesses where i don't
i haven't even talked to the ceo for
like
three or four months i don't even know
what their numbers are and what we've
realized is that when you leave people
alone and trust them
usually good things happen and the more
involved we get the worse the businesses
do
you have a cool quote here most
successful people are just walking
anxiety
disorders harnessed for productivity um
i completely agree i think
there's this um i have some
a friend was telling me about this book
i'm gonna read but basically they
said something like a lot of great
leaders um who we look up to
have horrible personality disorders you
know
or portable um flaws so for example
jfk um was was addicted to
a painkiller because he was he had a lot
of issues and he was addicted to drugs
um abe lincoln um he tried to kill
himself a couple times and he was very
suicidal and he had horrible depression
same with theodore roosevelt horrible
depression his
wife and his newborn daughter died on
the same day uh
he had a he was very sad and but
these types of personalities are really
good during wartime um
they're good because it gives them
they're like a dog that has to chase a
car
and they feel comfortable in that in
that mode
and when i see you saying that you have
to do the next thing and also that
successful people
are a walking dis anxiety disorder i
agree with you
i think that that is true but then i
also say to myself
then why would i feel bad about chasing
things all the time
um like why would i say like well the
most successful people are just like 10
to 20 years sitting
and and i just feel guilty about wanting
to do [__] all the time i'm like well
because i'm just a guy and i'm built to
go and do this [__]
because of how my brain is built and
that is just who i am and i will not
feel guilty for that yeah you're like a
golden retriever and you like to chase
balls
and nothing is gonna change that in your
brain unless maybe you take like some
drug or something like that
yeah so i don't think it's i don't know
if it's bad but it's more like the
you know i envy the people who can slow
down but i don't
necessarily know that i want that i
don't know if i could deal with that
right like i love
my ideal day is actually like meeting a
whole bunch of people
and looking at a bunch of problems and
looking at a bunch of different
businesses
as well as family and friends and
exercise
but if you take away the work part i
don't really do very well i kind of need
three four hours of work every single
day and
uh so i think there's just this natural
yin and yang of like you know
i over get overwhelmed and then i scale
down and then i have white space and
then i immediately scale back up because
i'm like
oh i have white space i can do more
stuff what about um
this photo booth business so that i was
going to talk about
like someone who i really admire and
this is just
this is genius so i met this guy
probably five or six years ago
uh really interesting local serial
entrepreneur
and um he has this business that's a
passport photo booth right and in
victoria
there's a passport office it's in the
mall there's only one of them
he has the passport photo office right
outside or sorry
the passport photo place right outside
the canadian passport thing
so as people walk in and they go oh [__]
i need a passport photo
he's got the booth right there right and
i was just like that is a freaking
amazing business
it spits out like i don't know how much
but you know a good life for him
and it just creates this base for him
and i was like that's the ultimate and
this guy he has like three or four
businesses
um but he also just like mountain bikes
and surfs all the time
and seems to like do whatever he wants
right this guy and he's always giving me
[__] being like dude come surfing with
me like why aren't you
enjoying life and stuff um and uh
really really interesting guy but it's
just an example of like the kind of
people who i'm like oh you've like
you've hacked it you've figured it out
you've got enough and you're always
doing enough interesting stuff that
you're
active but you also find time to do like
whatever the hell you want for three
four hours a day
so why do you have a personal scorecard
but what is this
uh so chris and i like i would say kovid
like hit us super hard over the winter
we were so busy we took that company
public like it was just an exhausting
year
and we were like we need a personal
scorecard to do
we try and do this like once a month or
so where we just sit down and ask
ourselves these questions and if enough
of them
are negative then we'll be like okay we
gotta change something
so some of them are like um you know
when you're with your kids are you
present
are you taking your kids out for one on
ones at least twice a month
have you had any calls in the last week
that you would just not want to do
have you had more than two hours of
calendar scheduled time per day
are you reading interesting books you
pre proud of your body
you know just like basic stuff that
encompasses your life
and it's been really really interesting
and useful
to just force yourself to ask those
questions because so often the answers
are no
looking at this so whenever you come on
you send me this huge document this
document
i contributed a little bit to it but a
lot of it's yours it's 2 000 words did
you write this what the hell
are you serious it's 18 it's 18 or 19.
jesus that's crazy did you write this
yeah yeah
i i didn't write the the research on the
billy of the week but i
wrote the rest that's crazy yeah so
we're gonna save this and we're gonna
have to come back and talk about it all
because
we also asked people on twitter so we
got a bunch of questions about meta lab
uh building a meta lab in india of
course we got tons of newsletter
questions we got tons of tax questions
which is kind of an interesting
one and then of course we get the same
question of like what would you do if
you started now
um we'll we'll actually answer them next
time
so hopefully we can record on tuesday i
don't know if you're available
but uh when your episodes are some of
the most popular
um this month we're gonna cross six
hundred thousand downloads and uh you're
a big part of that thank you this is fun
i always love having you here because
i feel like when we talk i'm more of a
fan than a co-host
dude i just love coming on because it's
not like
you guys have such a unique format and
it's so awesome to see you guys actually
like getting
huge right like i feel like i i remember
listening to you guys like two years ago
and you're like my only podcast
subscription basically
so it's awesome to see you getting so
big it's wicked
yeah last week we were ranked 14. the
goal by the end of the year was top 10.
i think that we're cracking the code i
think there's a world
where when you think of like business
podcasts it will be like of course like
jocko because he's like up there
it'll be tim ferriss because he's been
the best for a while and then there's
guy razz he's been the best for a while
but i think there's a world where we're
going to be up there
um in a very short amount of time and
i'm excited for that and you're part of
it so like
as we as our podcast gets bigger because
you're the most popular guest so are you
awesome no i i love doing these it's so
fun uh
thank you dude well let's do yeah next
week let's do an ama or whatever
and yeah we'll do that we should get
sean on and do do a full-on ama
we're gonna i'm gonna ask him his baby's
just now old enough where
uh maybe he's he's he isn't having his
back yeah he's getting his life back so
we're gonna do it sean and i are in
austin on june
3rd and then miami june 4th and then you
want to come and travel and do some [__]
with that yeah
i just did the canadian border i've got
a mandatory 14-day quarantine
yeah but they're going to reopen soon so
once it's reopened i'd love to do it
live
great we already have it all lined up
and
daddy hubspot we'll we'll foot the bill
we're good to go
open bar all right thank you andrew this
is awesome
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on a road let's travel never looking
back